حيث اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني يبردو منزليسكي
استعاده مدينه خيرسون ووصف هذا الحدث
بتاريخ
ان الوحدات الخاصه في الجيش الاوكراني
موجوده حاليا وسط المدينه
الى الاستسلام
قواتنا اصبحت داخل المدينه المواطنون
انتظروا جنودنا انا سعيد جدا على الرغم من
التهديدات الروسيه الناس يخرجون الى
الشوارع ويزيلون كل اثار العدوان الروسي
ستعيد اوكرانيا كل ما هو كلها قواتنا
سيطرت على كل المواقع وسوف تبدا اجراءات
اعاده الاستقرار الى اخرسيون وفي مقدمتها
ازاله الالغام لقد تركت القوات الروسيه
الكثيره منها قوات الدفاع ستؤهل كل شيء
وستعود المشافي الى عملها سنعيد الحياه من
جديد
وقد شهدت العاصمه كيا باحتفالات اسرائيل
على دخول قوتها المسلحه مدينه خيرسون بعد
انسحاب القوات الروسيه من الضفه الغربيه
من نهر
الاوكرانيه ودعم القوات المسلحه التي
قالوا انها تحقق انتصارات متتاليه في
جبهات القتال